hello and welcome back first it was BLM
going belly up and now there are serious
concerns that America's top racism Guru
has squandered tens of millions of
dollars Dr Ibraham X Kendy has made a
fortune lecturing white liberals on how
hateful they are thanks to his
best-selling 2019 book how to be
anti-racist watch
well actually teaching people to see
racism there's a difference like the
race is a mirage but racism is real and
it's you know who's the most likely to
be harmed by racism are children and you
know who we're least likely to engage
about it our children you know that's
what's really compelling me to do this
work oh that he's really doing the
Lord's work after the death of George
Floyd Boston University hired Dr Kennedy
as a professor and allowed him to raise
tens of millions of dollars to start an
anti-racist Center a research center
well that was a huge mistake the college
has launched an inquiry into the center
over the allegations of financial
mismanagement it has only produced two
research papers since it started and
just had to lay off half the staff a
former employee describes Dr Kennedy as
some sort of power drunk Tyrant one
Professor who works there is asking what
happened to the money quote it's pretty
hard for me to imagine they blew through
30 million in two years we have reached
out to Dr Kennedy for comment we have
not heard back that's very surprising so
judge where do you think the money went
that's a lot of money 30 million dollars
for a research center well 30 million
dollars and two papers in two years now
if you have 30 people on staff or no not
30. 45 people and now they're down to
like 25 they cut them in half whatever
the number is so you could you didn't
pay them that 30 million dollars so it's
either embezzlement some kind of fraud
uh or you know it is
um you know being used for something we
don't know about and the sad part about
this is that it's disappointing that all
the money that was raised in the
aftermath of George Floyd uh whether
it's by BLM or by this gentleman it was
not used for those in the inner city for
those who needed it the most for young
kids for Education you know for this guy
who you know is apparently an egomaniac
who comes out and says you know I got
two papers and I know everything there
is to know about what's going on
um and and the problem is that that with
BLM and with this and with the
destruction that happened after George
Floyd the neighborhoods and the
businesses and the communities the
president is there now everybody knows
that you can burn down a buildings and
neighborhoods and businesses if you're
upset about it and there won't be any
consequences to you and you know this
guy you know is is he's a disappointment
and he lectures us on what's wrong with
our culture when in reality it's what's
wrong with him yeah and you had a lot of
people who are working at the center who
really looked up to him and and wanted
to continue the work that he had started
and there his most vocal critics saying
that he is an authoritarian he is
abusive and there are a lot of
redundancies there and they have no idea
where the money went so are people being
racist questioning the good doctor oh I
don't think I hadn't even heard that
which is a nice break from the usual
conversation about these things and he
says that they're moving to a quote
Fellowship model we'll see how that goes
that's sexist women can't be fellows
good point Greg thank you
think we can
okay okay
um
things like this happen in higher
education too often and you know people
who are critics of them always say well
the money could have been spent this way
and this happens on both sides right you
have your your pet projects your ideas
that you think are more important so you
say well we could have taken that 30
million dollars and we could have done
this and I wish there was infinite money
that we could make sure that we
eradicate all problems facing Us in
society but spending money on something
like this which by the way for Boston
University gets a lot of kids to want to
come there right to be part of these
conversations gets academics to want to
leave wherever they are to come to be
part of this anti-racist Center I hope
they get to the bottom of wherever this
money is going and also take a long look
at the
unbelievable amount of money that is
pumped through these institutions and
are not doing what you should be with
the money which is educating kids and
giving kids also more of a shot at going
to these institutions giving more
scholarship money living off your
endowments more than just taking and
taking it well they are taking from the
federal government
the more you have the federal government
and involved in education like this but
it's not surprising that Boston
University fell for a scam like this is
it no no one could have ever seen this
coming Kennedy not in a million years
would this guy lose 30 million dollars
Jessica this doesn't happen all the time
when do people just lose 30 million
dollars I've never seen this happen 30
million dollars is gone
and this guy is like getting
investigated by Boston University how
about the IRS gets involved how about
the U.S attorney up in the Commonwealth
of Massachusetts gets involved this is a
massive scam and everyone's dancing
around it because he's black you know
who cares what color he is he just stole
30 million dollars which could have been
used for scholarships for African
Americans at Boston University and
that's the point when you're in the
racism industry you don't want racism to
go away you want to perpetuate it and
that's what he was doing he was teaching
people to see racism think about how
crazy that is he wasn't trying to get
rid of racism he was teaching people to
go in and look for racism wherever they
could find it now it's funny that racism
is going away but the racism industry is
getting bigger and I just hope that this
guy spends lots of time Behind Bars
because that's what he deserves does he
disorganize racism in order to get it no
you also don't need people making up
racism like the professor who created
institutional racism they just found out
he fraudulently concocted all the data
in his research reports and now he's
been fired institutional racism doesn't
exist well it's racist if we don't bring
Greg that's true because I identify as a
black man and I want to say this nobody
went to be you to take to go to this
Center they go to BU to drink and you
don't on it no no parent wants their kid
to be educated by this nonsense this
direct however I got to give him credit
it's a great scam he married the
accusations of racism to not funding his
escapades because if BLM taught us
anything besides how to Riot it's that
there are millions of white virtue
signaling folks ready and eager to part
with their money so they won't be called
racist it's a great scam it's a I give
him credit as for his employees now
turning on him we talked about this
before you never hire people who put
their pronouns in their resume because
they're making a personal demand up
front and they're going to turn on you
because it's all about me me me how
ironic is it that the king of Oppression
is now being accused of being an
oppressor by the very people that he
hired it's a red flag for trouble you
don't hire those people he did
I love it I love it hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else